أهالي المختطفين ونحن هنا من أجلهم
وبالطبع آخر شيء أريد القيام به هو ذلك
نصل إلى الشاطئ وبالعكس نصنع ثمانية
في الهواء وكل شيء لا يوجد سوى تلميح لشيء مختطف في الفضاء
نحن نبذل قصارى جهدنا للعثور عليه، وقد وجدنا اثنين
هويات عائلة ميريام التي وجدناها في بيمبا
ميش من روز وهذا الأسبوع وجدنا أيضًا السيد موافق
حسنًا، في الواقع أنت تعرف ما أريد
كن حذرا مع كلامي وليس ربما من الظل
وجدنا
كيف يشيرون إليك بالتوقف عن الحديث وجدنا صعوبة
لي مع هذه الأشياء لأننا ننسى ذلك في النهاية
لقد كان هؤلاء الأشخاص يقتلون كل يوم خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية
كان مئات الأشخاص مئات الأشخاص يوميًا
ربما يقومون بتحرير السكان المدنيين من السلطة
داني ربما بأي ثمن كانت هناك أم واحدة قتلوا
يجب على الأطفال على الأقل أن يتحدثوا عن ذلك ويقولوا
إنها دقيقة، دقيقة، أعطها ثانية، أعطها ثانية، أعطها ثانية
أعطيه لحظة، هذا هو الواقع الآن في غزة
وليس هذا الحذر وهذا الحذر الشديد
الحرب ليست كذلك
بسبب البيمبا يجوز قتل الأطفال
طفل طفل
نعم، هذه القطعة جيدة، ربما هكذا
الجنود الذين يتصرفون بمثل هذه الفرحة القاتلة أمر جيد
انتهى، ولكن في النهاية، ما يحدث هنا لا يرى هنا
شاشتك
برأيي الشخصي أقول رأيي الشخصي هنا
ليس باسم النظام، رأيي أنك عبرت أم
ليأتي الحدود ويقولون إن الجنود هم جنود تسافا
الدفاع عن إسرائيل يعمل بكل سرور على قتل جنود السلاحف
الدفاع عن إسرائيل ر. قوات الدفاع الثانية الثانية
ذهبوا إلى إسرائيل للدفاع عن الهجوم الإسرائيلي ضد آل
دولة إسرائيل من الهجوم والخوف والتهديد الوجودي
وبعد أن قتلوا منا 12 وخطفوا منا المئات
الناس إلى غزة، تعالوا ووضعوا الأشياء
النسب
هذا جدها
عرش جادون
حسنًا، سأواجه صراعًا
إنه أمر صعب، وإذا نجحنا فقد يراق المزيد من الدماء
في الشوارع يؤخذ هذا أيضًا في الاعتبار بسبب الكتائب
بانجر بالفعل
مسلحين حينها لكن لا يمكننا الالتقاط
الأيدي بسبب هذه الحقائق لا يمكنك ذلك
ارفع يديك
وأقول مرة أخرى أن هذه الرسالة يجب أن تُبث
وهذا التصميم يجب على الجميع التحدث إلى 10E
الناس ونقل نفس الرسالة لهم ويكون على علم بها
سوف يتحدثون مع بعضهم البعض حتى في الحرب النفسية
أحد هذه الأشياء يذهب إلى أعدائنا للأسف
ولسوء الحظ، فإننا نؤمن أيضًا أن اثنين هما في الحقيقة الله أيضًا
أمام العائلات، فكروا في أن ما يعنيه ذلك ليس مهمًا
هزيمة حماس ليست مهمة لإعادة المختطفين
المهم هو تغيير رئيس الوزراء مهما كان
من حمير بام حمرات رئيس أركاننا السابق في الواقع
من وقت الحرب بيننا نتحدث عن رجال مسلحين سيقاتلون
وأنه ممنوع الاستعداد، وقد حان وقت الدم بالتحديد في الشوارع
وحان الوقت للتوقف عن تفسيرها
على المستوى الإعلامي وبدأ التعامل معه على هذا المستوى
الدستوري مجرم حيثما توجد جريمة هنا
ويجب على الدولة أيضًا تطبيق قانون الجرائم
هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين لا أعرفهم في نظري خطرون ومؤذون
في ما يتعلق بأمن دولة إسرائيل، علينا أن نبدع ونحتاج إلى البحث
ويتأثر بها
القانون